one of the many joys of watching sports
these days is that you get warmed over
ham-handed leftist politics thrown in
your face all the time and it is a great
joy the NFL has printed the words end
racism in the end zone for several years
now for example apparently hasn't worked
yet because the message is still there
uh or or maybe racism is solved and they
just forgot to remove it I don't know
any event the NFL isn't alone the US
Open just plastered equal pay propaganda
all over the court Major League Baseball
even had BLM stencil on the mountain for
a while there and so on and it's so
pervasive and so on the nose that it's
enough to make you give up on
professional sports entirely on
Saturdays you might find yourself taking
a hard look at say Third Rate division 3
college football games instead you might
think surely all the social engineering
won't be on display there at that level
right how much of this Insanity could
have possibly filtered down into a game
that no one's watching like the match up
between I don't know say shannondell
University and uh Juniata College from
last week weend if you've ever found
yourself you know thinking along those
lines unfortunately though we have some
bad news even the d-list football games
including the game between Shannon DOA
and that other school that I can't
pronounce have become yet another
opportunity for corporate media to tell
you that 2 plus 2 equals 7 they are more
Grist for the leftist ideology Mill that
has its tentacles everywhere now so
here's the Today Show to explain the
significance of shannond doa's recent
highly anticipated game that only five
people watched watch we're back 738 with
some inspiring history that was made in
college football over this weekend yeah
for the first time ever a woman played
in an NCAA game at a position that was
not kicker her name is Haley van vores
and we cannot wait to talk to her but
first NBC's Kaye H Hartung has her
Amazing Story Kaylee good morning hey
good morning guys so after more than two
years on her college football team
without seeing any game action Haley
told me she felt like she was in a movie
when she stepped on the field
Saturday inspiring history was made an
amazing story now it's important to stop
the clip there to note a couple things
first of all uh they got the the facts
wrong um not that anyone's keeping track
but Haley van Voris was not in fact the
first female non- kicker or punter to
play in an NCAA game that honor went to
quarterback Taylor Kraut who played a
game for Fitchburg State earlier this
year nobody remembers that because kout
managed to make one quote assisted
tackle before leaving the game but as
long as facts matter which they clearly
don't because the point of this segment
is to advance a fraudulent narrative
anyway uh still we'll just throw that
out there more to the point there's
another unanswered question which is
this how does NBC News know that Haley
was in fact the first female playing in
a non-kicking role in a game pretending
that she actually was that which she
wasn't but if a if a female is anyone
who thinks they're female and that's the
standard we have to accept or else we're
transphobes and how do we know that
dozens of other Brave females aren't
playing college football right now how
do we know that uh women haven't already
been inducted into the Pro Football Hall
of Fame has anyone checked with dick
budus or Ray Lewis to see if they still
identify as men when the left talks
about homosexuality in contexts like
this they usually use the term openly
gay so they'll say that so and so was
the first openly homosexual person to
play football or whatever but in this
case they're not using that terminology
they're not talking about openly female
or openly woman uh players here they're
not saying that you know Haley is the
first openly female non-kicking player
they're just flat out declaring that
she's the first female player and the
first woman I mean it's almost as if the
left knows that those words have meaning
and and every now and then they
accidentally admit it I don't know but
back to this history making game so
let's uh let's take another look at at
why everyone is pretending to celebrate
what Haley did here's the sum total of
her contribution to that game watch the
5'6 came into the game with division 3
Shen andoa up 26 points against Juniata
College registering a quarterback hurry
on the way to a Shannon DOA win did that
quarterback know what or who hit him
I've had some people come up to after
the game until I take my helmet off
they're like dude I didn't know you were
even a
girl so
um first of all I'm pretty sure they do
know and notice that she doesn't answer
the question there did the quarterback
know what or who had hit him in her
respon says well bet people come up to
me and tell me they didn't know I was a
girl so this is just speculation of
course but maybe she's dodging the
question because the quarterback knew
exactly what had happened there and
maybe he he let her know about it I mean
this woman just ran at him totally
unblocked then for some reason decided
to cling on to him long after he threw
the ball to his receiver and eventually
after a couple seconds she drags him to
the turf almost like it's happening in
slow motion now in any other context if
you don't know anything about football
what you saw in that play there that is
a roughing the passer penalty worth 50
15 yards and it's so clear that if it
was a man making that same play a ref
who for some reason was standing in the
end zone 80 yards away would throw that
flag there would be Flags falling out of
the sky
everywhere if in a situation like that
where the the receiver's already caught
the ball and is in the process of being
tackled and you are still trying to
tackle the
quarterback that's 15 yards and maybe an
ejection from the game
potentially but that didn't happen to
this uh this woman because none of the
refs wanted to interrupt the girl power
moment here and uh neither did anyone
else watching it so everybody just
pretended that they had seen something
really impressive and here's how the
Washington Post described the footage
that you just saw quote she got through
and managed to hit Juniata of
quarterback Calvin German an instant
after he had released the ball on what
became an incomplete
pass an instant they say really several
seconds what's the difference really I
mean in football the difference is quite
a lot and they say she managed to get
through by simply running straight at
the guy unblocked now for his part
Sports journalist Dove kimman said that
this was a groundbreaking moment in
college football history he said quote
Haley van Voris entered the game during
the four first quarter immediately
leaving her Mark with a QB hurry on a
crucial third down
play now to be clear again if you're not
familiar with football just so you know
her team was up 26 to nothing at the
time of this crucial third down play in
the first quarter they ultimately won
the game 48 to7 uh
there are no crucial plays in a game
that ends 48 to7 especially not in the
first quarter but who's counting in fact
there wouldn't have even been a camera
crew from ESPN watching this game at all
if they didn't think that this gender
angle might come into play but she was
put in the game as ESPN expected and so
now we're all supposed to imagine that
this was really a momentous movie like
moment so here here's how the Today's
Show uh played up Haley's tackle not a
QB rush but a tackle in their words
watch to me it was a it was just a big
moment to be able to crush my own goals
and then make a statement for just the
football community and you know show
that women can play the game at whatever
level that may be so here's where they
start to lay the propaganda on a little
too thick and they introduce an idea
that isn't just stupid it's it's
dangerous saying quote women can play
the game at whatever
level the NBC anchorwoman agrees and
says that later that haly is overcoming
stereotypes that are you know held by I
guess a bunch of
trogloditas of that which could very
soon lead to a lot of dead women on
football fields it's important to
understand the scope of the problem here
because this is not a one-off incident
college football teams are increasingly
promoting the idea that women and men
can play at the same level and can be on
the field in a violent combat sport
together all also last weekend a woman
named uh Leilani armenta was handling
kickoff or kickoff duties for Jackson
State and there were a couple of
injuries so the coaches put her in and
this is for their matchup against the
PowerHouse players for bethon cookman
and here's how her kickoff went watch
this and here's the story of the day
right there that is Lani armenta and
she's going to play and she's going to
kick off and maybe even do some field
goes tonight for the Jackson State
Tigers of course she was on the Jackson
State women's soccer team and because of
injuries this week during practice she's
going to get her shot tonight to be a
kicker and what an impressive young lady
has been and a chance for her and I I'm
sure she's pretty nervous at this point
but they have her out there and SWAT
football is
underway oh Lord uh first of all if you
if you turn on a a football game and you
hear this is the story of the day right
here and when they say that you're
looking at the uh at the kicker doing a
kickoff that already tells you even if
it's a man that tells you this is a very
boring game if the story of the day is
the guy doing
kickoffs uh and if it's the woman doing
kickoff then it's even worse so the ball
goes 25 yards which is and I'm not I'm
not just trying to make fun of her it's
the kind of kicking that you see on a
bad High School JV team like it's that
level in fact it's worse than that are
you a few years or maybe even decades
out of school and wondering what the
heck did I even learn and what was the
point you might think to yourself that
you don't have time to learn something
new and if that's you then know this
you're not alone and it's not too late
since 1844 Hillsdale College has been
providing education and Faith freedom
and character theyve taken some of the
core classes they teach on campus and
they've made them available for free
online for anyone who wants to learn
that's right it is free there are 39
free courses to choose from ranging from
the US Constitution the Book of Genesis
to uh free market economics they're easy
to follow and self-pay so you can start
whenever you want in fact you can start
right now it's everything that you need
all in one place with no long-term
commitment let H Hillsdale College be
your guide learn when and where you want
you can't lose go right now to
hillsdale.edu Walsh to enroll there's no
cost easy to get started that's
hillsdale.edu Walsh to register
hillsdale.edu
Walsh now a lot of people went on social
media to suggest that maybe it was a bad
idea to have a woman attempt this
kickoff because it uh you know kind of
an obvious point to make and and also by
the way that is dangerous too it's not
like this is a nonon position
necessarily on a kickoff especially if
you're really bad at doing kickoffs um
you there's a pretty good chance that
the other team's going to have a return
and then you're going to be a position
where you've got you know a 6
foot6 200 plus pound uh guy running with
a full head of steam right at you as the
kicker but again sports journalists
maybe the dumbest and least original
form of journalist on the planet which
is really saying something jumped into
action so here's how one local reporter
named Bradley Davis responded to all the
haters online who had an issue with that
objectively terrible kickoff watch all
right now before we go we need to talk
about what happened last night after
Leilani armenta took the field for
Jackson State as the first woman to play
in a D1 HBCU football game now just like
anytime a woman does anything in a male
dominated sport the social media
Warriors they made sure we all knew that
there was a man who could have done it
better and it was just a publicity stunt
to take advantage of when the other
kickers got hurt and now first of all
have you think TC Taylor a true son of
Jackson State who's waited years to get
this opportunity wouldn't run out the
player he thought gave his team the best
chance to win in his first ever home
game as head coach man you really
haven't been paying attention now maybe
it's just harder to do than you think it
is and maybe you didn't take care to
look beyond the surface leani played
three years of varc football in high
school she made 98 out of 105 extra
point attempts in her career she also
suited up when coach Taylor called
despite recovery from ACL surgery maybe
you chose to ignore that brace she had
on her kicking leg so next time you get
mad watching a woman play football
because they could have found a man to
do it better go out and kick 105 extra
points let me know how many of those you
make yeah of course uh well no they just
put her on the field CU she had gave him
the best possible chance to win a woman
with a brace on her kicking leg was the
best person available there was no one
we know that's not true you can just
pick any guy on the team pick a lineman
and just put him out there to kick the
ball and he would at least do uh as well
as that but probably better and by the
way they had to go to the girl soccer
team to find a kicker they do they not
have a guy soccer
team now this is not to pick on Bradley
Davis he's obviously a smug guy out
there saying what he has to say if he
ever wants to advance in the industry of
sports journalism this was his ESPN
audition tape but it's worth knowing
that he's presenting uh noting that he's
presenting an an embarrassing
embarrassingly bad argument that's
typical on the left first of all there's
no reason for Bradley Davis to be
talking about this woman's extra point
attempts in high school she wasn't
kicking extra points in the clip we just
showed you she was attempting a kickoff
which requires a lot more leg strength
than an extra point to pull off and she
completely failed and she humiliated
herself in the process of attempting
that kickoff it's a pretty significant
fact that Bradley Davis somehow forgot
to mention but let's just ignore that
for a second the thrust of this smug
reporter's argument is that first of all
people are only criticizing her terrible
kickoff because she's a woman but if
you've spent even five seconds around
any football fan anywhere you know that
they will viciously criticize any player
who screws up that badly a male kicker
who only manages to send the ball 25
yards will certainly be mocked
ruthlessly for it so if you want women
to be treated like men accepted into the
boys club and all that then it means
that they will also be ruthlessly
criticized for their failures because
that's what it means to be treated like
a man that's how we men operate
that's how we treat each other if you
screw up we're going to tell you and
we're not going to be nice about it so
if you really want to be I'm part of the
boys club okay well this is what it
means you do a kickoff like that and we
are going to mock you
endlessly now the reporter also says
that unless you can kick extra points as
well as this woman then you should shut
up you're not allowed to have any kind
of opinion on this topic whatsoever
what's impressive about this line of
argument is is is what a massive absurd
straw man it is because no one is saying
that any random guy off the street could
necessarily beat this woman in an
impromptu extra point competition only
because she's been kicking extra points
for years and most people have never
even tried to kick an extra point uh the
point is that the best women football
players at all positions are nowhere
near as good as the best male football
players at that position or even the
10th best male football player or the
50th best okay like you take a woman at
any football position at any level and
you will easily find
the best woman the best woman at any
football position at any level you will
easily find 50 100 you'd find 500 male
football players better than the best
one at that position for a woman and
even that is probably under selling it
now we know that because there has never
been a female player this woman most
certainly included who can outperform
men at a high level of play in a sport
like this we also know it because
biology is real and men have
dramatically more upper and lower body
strength than women this is why
literally every time they Tred out a
woman to substitute for a male player in
football it's a catastrophe you may
remember Sarah Fuller she was she made
history as a female college football
kicker a few years ago she kicked it
something like 30 yards so a little bit
longer than this other woman and the
media lied after the fact to claimed
that it was a planned squib kick even
though it was a situation on the field
where no team would ever intentionally
squib the ball now in case you've
forgotten about that historic kick it's
worth revisiting including the buildup
beforehand because it's truly a modern
classic uh watch we are about to witness
history in college football Vanderbilt
commodor coming back onto the field they
will kick off to start the second half
and Sarah Fuller will kick off for
Vanderbilt to become the very first
woman to compete in the Southeastern
Conference in a football game and a
power five football game and there she
is wearing number 32 her soccer jersey
number and just 6 days ago was winning
an SEC soccer tournament championship in
Orange Beach
Alabama and wouldn't you know it history
is on the field in Columbia Missouri as
Sarah Fuller is about to put her right
foot into a football speaking volumes to
women around the
[Applause]
world awesome awesome moment you can
hear the crowd everybody understands
what's happening right now this is
pretty cool moment
and the kick down at the 35 yd line and
Sarah
Fuller Happy
Thanksgiving what a day what a day in
college
football what a day now notice how the
crowd is really excited and loud and
then they see the kick and they just go
silent they don't know what to do they
don't know how to respond meanwhile the
announcers continue to read their
prepared lines like they just witnessed
the moon landing what a day in college
football they declare after witnessing
the worst kick anyone would see until
the next time a woman kicked the ball
it's impossible not to notice just how
patronizing all this is by the way
Jackie Robinson is remembered and
celebrated not just because he broke the
color line but because he was a truly
great player so when we talk about
Jackie Robinson we're not saying wow
look at that black player trying his
best isn't it cute no he actually earned
the respect that he gets for his play
he's one of the alltime greats but as
the media desperately tries to find
their female Jackie Robinson it never
works like this the girls are laughably
awful and everyone can tell they don't
deserve to be on the field it turns out
that unlike the color line the gender
line exists for a very legitimate reason
now Sarah Fuller's historically awful
kick was only a few years ago now we've
already gotten to the point where a
college football team actually put a 5
foot 6 inch blonde chick on the field to
play defense okay when the Sarah Fuller
thing happened people like me said that
that this is where it was headed and
everyone assumed we were joking couple
years later they're actually doing it
now fortunately for her the other team
didn't pull a guard over to make a block
with a head of steam knocking her in
next
week when women are on the field the
players so far have been playing along
and kind of letting her have a Rudy
moment but it's not going to stay like
that forever eventually one of these
guys will treat one of these girls like
a football player and it's quite
possible that we'll see a death on the
the field because of it and then what's
going to happen is the male player will
be demonized and have to live with the
trauma the rest of his life when really
it's the fault of the school and the
media that valued girl power over the
safety of the players this will happen
okay even in this modern woke era the
football field is still a place where
very big and fast men violently Clash
you keep throwing women into that mix it
it won't be long before something very
bad happens which is why in a sane
Society women would be banned from
competing against men in violent sports
like this and in the past you know no
such rule was necessary because nobody
was crazy enough to actually put a woman
on the field now people are that crazy
and so we need policies that reflect
that
reality but nationally of course
everyone is ignoring the reality
colleges and corporate media are
insisting with a straight facee that
women should be playing football with
men and if you ask any questions about
this Sports reporters will lecture you
and call you a
bigot this was always the inevitable
result of the theatrical game of make
believe that we're all supposed to take
part in the underlying message as always
is that men and women are exactly the
same no difference but everyone knows
that isn't true and one thing we've
learned time and time again is that
eventually one way or another reality
always reasserts itself especially on
the football field and when it does
you're not going to like the
result hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code should
get two months free on all annual plans
see you there